Estamos aquí.
Miren a quién tengo.
Voy a meter la mano.
Y no lo consiguió.
Lo hiciste tú.
Buenas tardes.
Soy Alicia Sierra,
para los que no lo saben.
Y me encargaré de la
negociación de este atraco.
Empieza la fiesta.
Profesor.
Inspectora Sierra,
qué alegría.
Tenía ganas
de hablar con usted.
Sí, ya sé
que le gustan mucho
las negociadoras
de la policía.
¿No me va a preguntar
qué llevo puesto?
Ropa de maternidad.
Profesor.
Lleva cinco minutos viudo
y ya está llamando
a otras mujeres.
Pillo. Usted es un Don Juan.
¿Dio usted
la orden de ejecutarla?
No me dio tiempo.
Lo hizo ella misma.
Raquel Murillo
se resistió con violencia,
abriendo fuego
contra sus excompañeros,
- como una traidora.
- Escúcheme, Sierra.
Antes de que salgamos
del Banco de España
usted quedará fulminada.
Qué aburrido.
¿No será usted
profesor de ética?
Aténgase
a las consecuencias.
Sí, estoy temblando
de miedo.
Pero en señal
de buena voluntad,
le ofrezco
una tregua de 48 horas.
Así puede evaluar
la gravedad de la herida.
O dejar que muera ahí.
Acepto la tregua.
Pero escúcheme bien.
Nairobi va a sobrevivir
con o sin su ayuda.
Ya le di la exclusiva
a un diario nacional.
La llamarán en breve
para confirmar lo de la
tregua. Espero que lo haga.
¿Por qué habría de hacerlo?
Porque, si no lo hace,
filtraré que fingieron
asesinar a Lisboa.
Que la tienen retenida
ilegalmente desde entonces
y que se niegan
a llevarla ante un juez.
Son pequeñeces, profesor.
También tengo
las grabaciones
de la supuesta ejecución.
- Qué hijo de puta.
- También podría contar
que están negociando
capturar o no
a la hija y a la abuela
en el Sudeste Asiático.
Pero, sinceramente,
entre usted y yo,
a eso ya llegan tarde.
¡Por Nairobi!
Quieto.
Jaque mate, hijo de puta.
Me amenazaron muchas veces
con dispararme.
Pues, mira. Sin amenazas.
Vaya. Qué autocontrol.
Entrégueme a la policía.
Error.
Si te llevo a la policía,
te escapas.
Si te llevo a la cárcel,
también.
Te lleve adonde te lleve,
tienes un jodido plan
y te escapas.
Y dime.
Contesta de una puta vez.
¿Por dónde
vas a sacar el oro?
Si me tira,
no podrá limpiar su nombre.
- ¿Por dónde?
- ¿Qué les va a entregar?
¿Un cuerpo aplastado?
¿Un cuerpo tiroteado?
- El oro.
- Va a quedar como una loca.
Muy bien. A volar.
Estamos aquí.
Miren a quién tengo.
A ver... Aquí estamos,
en la guarida
de este astuto animalejo.
El Profesor.
Sr. Marquina,
salude a la cámara.
¿Sr. Marquina?
- No creo que sea necesario.
- Claro que sí.
A ver.
Díganos, Sr. Profesor.
¿Quién lo detuvo?
- Usted.
- ¿Usted quién?
Haga su parte.
Me detuvo
la inspectora Alicia Sierra.
Exactamente.
Me cago en tu vida.
Cierra la puta boca.
¡Marsella!
Te voy a volar la puta
cabeza. Cállate la boca.
¡Marsella! ¡Código rojo!
¡Marsella! ¡Benjamín!
¡Marsella!
El oro.
Eso ya no importa.
Claro que importa, imbécil.
No está entendiendo nada.
El oro ya no importa.
- Cállese.
- Usted está condenada,
imputada por los mismos
delitos que nosotros,
- pero peor en su caso...
- Cállese.
- ...porque hay desacato.
La convirtieron en traidora.
- Cállese.
- La policía, el Estado
y todos sus compañeros.
Y de allí no se regresa.
Nadie la librará
de la cárcel.
¡Cállese
que necesito pensar!
No.
Rompió aguas.
Mire, usted puede odiarme
todo lo que quiera.
Puede desear mi muerte.
Lo que sea.
Pero en este momento,
para salvar su vida
y la de su hijo,
debe salvar la mía.
En este momento
estamos en el mismo lugar.
Somos iguales.
Te odio.
Muy bien.
Pero ahora
no tenemos tiempo,
y ese odio que me tiene
no le da derecho
a poner en riesgo
la vida de ese bebé.
Este bebé...
adora el riesgo,
hijo de puta.
¡Vamos, cariño!
¡Un poquito más
y ya estás fuera!
¡Mierda!
¡No sale!
¡No sale! ¿Por qué?
Porque no es la cabeza.
¿Qué?
Viene de nalgas.
- ¿Qué hago?
- Hay que...
introducir la mano,
colocar al niño
sobre el brazo,
como si estuviera
cabalgando,
sujetarle la boca
con el índice y el pulgar,
acercar la cabeza
al esternón
y entonces sacarlo.
No hay otra manera.
Y hay que hacerlo ya.
Tiene que soltarme.
¡No!
Marsella, sábanas.
Benjamín, agua limpia.
Escúcheme bien.
Empiece a respirar hondo.
Respire hondo.
Eso es.
Y muy importante.
Ahora no puede pujar.
Voy a meter la mano.
¿De acuerdo?
Va a salir bien.
Vamos a hacerlo.
Cúbranse.
...una terrible explosión.
Victoria.
Se va a llamar Victoria.
- Se va a llamar Victoria.
- Está muy bien.
Se va a llamar Victoria.
Porque va a salir adelante
como una bomba.
Y yo con ella.
- Profesor.
- Sierra se llevó un auto.
- ¿Qué?
- Pero vamos tras ella.
¿Se te escapó
una recién parida
con un bebé en brazos?
¿Le cantaste
el arroz con leche?
¿Se creyeron familia?
¿Qué carajo pasó?
Por un momento
perdí la cabeza.
Él. Está hasta en la sopa.
Es de seguridad.
No puedes apagar la cámara.
Alicia, sabemos dónde estás.
El auto está geolocalizado.
- Esto es absurdo.
- Ya lo creo.
- ¡Vamos!
Te lo dije.
No te queda otra
más que confiar en mí.
- ¡Vamos!
- ¿Sí?
¿Le puedo dejar a usted
la notificación?
Te abro.
Dame al bebé.
Y mis gafas.
Necesito mis gafas.
¡Vamos, rápido!
¡Policía!
¡Abra la puerta! ¡Policía!
¡La niña! ¡La niña!
La niña está dormida.
¿Sabe o no cuál es la llave?
Abajo.
Equipo Delta entrando.
Equipo Alfa en posición.
Equipo Bravo, primer piso
revisado y limpio.
¿Cuánto hace que no comes?
¿Qué día es hoy?
Voy a intentar preparar
algo caliente.
La M60
es una circunvalación.
Nunca la usarían
para huir de Madrid.
Porque no están huyendo.
Se están escondiendo.
Nadie huye con 90 toneladas
de oro de un país.
¿Qué haces con tanto dinero,
cuando tienes tanto oro
que no te lo puedes llevar?
¿Qué hacía Pablo Escobar?
- ¿Y los piratas?
- Enterrar el botín.
Por eso están usando
los volquetes.
- Eso es.
- El oro está bajo tierra.
- Correcto.
- ¿Dónde escondes ese botín?
Donde sea que haya sido,
el agujero para enterrar
90 toneladas de oro
tiene que dejar
tal movimiento
de tierras
y de maquinaria...
que aún
podemos encontrarlo.
La Interpol estuvo buscando
meses y meses
por todo el planeta
intentando localizarme.
Y no lo consiguió.
Lo hiciste tú.
En horas.
Te escapaste de una rueda de
prensa llena de periodistas.
Te escapaste de Tamayo,
de todo el cuerpo de Policía
estando embarazada de nueve
meses y me encontraste.
¡Por supuesto que vas
a encontrar ese oro!
Así que llévate
esos autos y esta banda...
y encuentra el botín
más grande de la historia.
¿Lucía?
Y el de Victoria.
¿Y el oro?
El oro ya está en Portugal.
En una casita.
La casita del tesoro.